[Music]
President Trump has been proven right
about wiretapping and guess what the
all-knowing holier than now destroy
Trump propaganda media has been caught
in a massive lie and a major cover-up
now the mainstream media has been
misleading all of you the American
people for months and months about this
story so tonight we will once again do
their job and set the record straight so
you have the facts now according to a
new report
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort was in fact wiretapped
by the FBI under FISA Court warrants
before and after the 2016 election
according to a reporting the FBI was
monitoring man afford over concerns that
he was communicating with quote Russian
operatives but what's even more
disturbing is this man afore was under
surveillance earlier this year when he
was known to be communicating with
President Trump Manta fort earlier
tonight put out a statement and is
demanding an investigation and to how
this information was leaked to the press
and he's also calling for the Obama
administration surveillance of a
political opponent to be investigated
also and also tonight the DOJ did say
earlier this month there was no evidence
that President Trump was directly
targeted for surveillance but they
didn't specify if the president was
incidentally caught up in this man
afford wiretap so for all of you lazy
overpaid ideological liberal mainstream
media people out there you have now been
exposed for the fraud you are yet again
and as we've been saying the biased
press they're not interested in
reporting the truth in fact they only
care about smearing and D legitimizing
President Trump and this is more
evidence and after President Trump
tweeted back in March March 4th that he
was wiretapped by President Obama or
people in his administration the
destroyed Trump media lost it
they were viciously mocking and
attacking him watch this the bottom line
is and always has been there is no
evidence that Donald Trump was
wiretapped by Barack Obama it was and
continues to be a lie our conspiracy
theory president is at it again and
whenever something like this happens I
wonder what are the Pres
sources of information where is he
getting these ideas and that has been
denied by President Obama by the former
Director of National Intelligence and
now we know it as well by the FBI
director they are all saying it did not
happen so is the president calling all
three of those individuals liars I don't
think they're taking seriously enough
how devastating this is to the American
system for one president to say my
predecessor wiretap John we have been
living in really through the Trump
campaign and unto this hour this
alternative reality the way that print
that Donald Trump seems to think about
what a president can do feels very Nick
Sounion that he has a much more inflated
view of a president's powers for him to
believe that a president could even in
theory because the election is ongoing
and tap her tap the opponent of his
preferred candidate Trump's mind is a
little bit of a mystery amazing the
conspiracy theory media lies to you
again now this is not surprising
considering the left-wing meetings like
an echo chamber they all find one topic
to attack the President on and they
repeat and repeat and repeat the same
talking points this is beyond pathetic
predictable frankly dangerous in a lot
of ways while the media was going after
President Trump on this program well we
actually tried to find out the truth
remember this was March 4th when the
president tweeted on March 8th on this
program circuit news as Sarah Carter
John Solomon they were reporting the
Trump's communications could have in
fact been caught up in this FISA warrant
that was in effect in October we were
way ahead of the curve here's what Sarah
Carter told us back then now there was
also a separate FISA it was an overall
FISA I don't have as much information on
that that FISA though was a general FISA
that covered the whole Russian hacking
investigation what we don't know is who
was connected to that FISA what was that
faisal looking at and that is very
highly classified nobody wants to talk
about that particular FISA right now
there is a distinction between a Feist
understand and then a wiretapping but
they did tap I mean you they were
looking so the truth was staring all
these so-called journalists
in the face the entire time they never
followed up on that story remember Sarah
Carter John Solomon they did all the
legwork for them of course they didn't
it doesn't fit their narrative their
ideological agenda they just rather
repeat each other's lies and conspiracy
theories then report the facts and
explain what's really going on something
you deserve and after breaking this
story well some of the anchors over at
the fake news network CNN even now they
finally are having to start to admit
that President Trump was right the
entire time after March 4th this
happened take a look hold on a second
Maggie because I do think it sounds like
the president was right if Paul Manafort
has a residence in Trump Tower and Paul
Manafort was being surveilled and
wiretapped
Trump Tower was wiretapping no it was
not I'm sorry how do you know well I
don't know but I know that what we know
so far does not indicate that Trump
Tower my lines as he put it were unless
you were saying that he owns every
single thing in Trump Tower president
came out about this way we all remember
those tweets on March 4th let me just
read them again for anyone who's
forgotten terrible just found out that
Obama had my quote wires tapped in Trump
Tower just before the victory nothing
found this is McCarthyism he continued
how low is President Obama gone to tap
my phones during the very sacred
election process this is Nixon Watergate
bad open parentheses or sick guy he was
derided for this but mark is he somehow
vindicated tonight so when will other
members of the establishment destroy
Trump meeting what are they going to
come forward admit they had it wrong now
there's a very important fact in this
story that cannot be ignored and that is
Obama's former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper he denied on
Meet the Press back in March that there
was ever any wiretapping as a president
Trump or his campaign and he also said
there was no evidence of a FISA Court
warrant warrant
listen to what he says watch this for
the part of the national security
apparatus that I oversaw as DNI there
was no such wiretap activity mounted
against the
the president-elect at the time were as
a candidate or against his campaign
there is no fuss a court order not not
to my knowledge of anything a Trump
Tower no wrong and shocking now clapper
needs to be hauled in front of Congress
and he needs to be ordered to testify
under oath about everything that he
knows and how he went on television and
said something that's not true because
guess what he doesn't appear to be
telling the truth yet again in the clip
we just showed you it's inexcusable I
hope tonight the Attorney General of the
United States Jeff Sessions is watching
the American people deserve to know the
truth
the mainstream establishment media is no
longer in the truth-telling business all
right also tonight President Trump he
stepped on the world stage earlier today
at the UN and wasted very little time in
confronting the many dangers America and
the world is now facing evil in our time
President Trump he took direct aim at
North Korea for its continued aggression
and he issued a direct warning to
dictator Kim jong-un and his rogue
regime take a look at this the United
States has great strength and patience
but if it is forced to defend itself or
its allies we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea Rocketman is
on a suicide mission for himself and for
his regime it is time for North Korea to
realize that the D nuclearization is
it's only acceptable future and what a
difference the president makes now
president Trump didn't stop with North
Korea he also focused on radical Islamic
mullahs in Tehran and the disastrous
Iranian nuclear deal look at this
we cannot abide by an agreement if it
provides cover for the eventual
construction of a nuclear program the
Iran deal was one of the worst and most
one-sided transactions the United States
has ever entered into frankly that deal
is an embarrassment to the United States
and I don't think you've heard
the last of it believe me now that deal
is an embarrassment to the United States
and we've not heard the last of it now
this is what leading on the world stage
actually looks like president Trump
refused to appease and capitulate to
countries like Iran and the hate America
crowd in North Korea countries that want
to see Israel wiped off the map in fact
President Trump is receiving very high
praise for his very bold and direct
address the Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu said it was the most
bold courageous speech he's ever heard
at the United Nations now President
Trump also outlined his plan to defeat
radical Islamic terrorism and called on
other countries to ramp up their efforts
in that fight modern-day evil and I've
got to say it's beyond refreshing and
encouraging that of a president who's
not afraid to call out radical Islamic
terrorism by name remember only a couple
of years ago President Obama did the
exact opposite at the UN and actually
said that Islam is the religion of peace
well for some yes but for many no and
finally during the major speech
president Trump defended American
sovereignty by declaring he as president
will always put America first later in
the program we will have Ambassador John
Bolton